l'influent soeur chinois l'ittihad qui a
disparu après avoir posté une vidéo avec
un gâteau voici ce qu'il s'est passé
leetchi 30 ans est suivi par des
millions de personnes en chine notamment
pour ses vidéos sur les rouges à lèvres
vendredi 3 juin il diffuse en live sur
weibo l'un des principaux réseaux
sociaux chinois il montre alors on
dirait que ce gâteau dont la forme
ressemble beaucoup à un char le symbole
du char est une référence à peine voilée
à la répression de tiananmen dont la
commémoration était prévue au lendemain
du live pour rappel le 4 juin 1989 les
autorités chinoises avaient tué des
centaines de manifestants pacifiques sur
la place du même nom peu de temps après
avoir montré le gâteau le live a été
brutalement interrompue depuis cette
interruption l'influent soeur de 30 ans
n'a rien posté sur ces réseaux alors
qu'il devait notamment publié une vidéo
très attendu ce dimanche 5 juin depuis
le début de la semaine les hashtag en
son nom sont de plus en plus partagée en
chine